un peu partout en europe un vent de
changement souffle doucement sur
l'industrie laitière de plus en plus de
producteurs s'interrogent sur la façon
d'élever les petits veaux parallèlement
à ça les consommateurs pose davantage de
questions alors comment concilier les
attentes de chacun avec les contraintes
de la production et la réalité
économique
voici l'exemple des pays-bas
[Musique]
voici une scène que l'on ne voit pas
souvent en production laitière 1 vous en
train de téter sa mère nous sommes dans
le sud des pays-bas à la ferme de cornée
en scène
[Musique]
depuis 2007 ce producteur laitier
conventionnelles ne sépare plus les
veaux de leur mère
c'est au début des années 2000 qu'il
entend parler de cette façon d'élever
les petites génisses mais il n'est pas
convaincu au ghana qu il avait parlé de
ça un congrès d'agriculture biologique
et je me suis d'abord dit ils sont fous
quelques années plus tard il décide tout
de même de se lancer dans l'aventuré
sur la ferme familiale cette nouvelle
façon d'élever les veaux qui semblent de
prime abord plus naturel représente tout
un défi
most ça demande un grand sens de
l'observation
mon père était très nerveux au début
parce que tout était nouveau
c'est bien plus facile de les mettre
dans une ruche et de leur donner du lait
comme ça on voit ce que le veau bois
s'il est malade abbott mais beaucoup de
chose lui manque aussi comme le contact
social la mère qui le lèche par exemple
les débuts sont difficiles il existe peu
de ressources pour guider l'agriculteur
qui fonctionne par essais et erreurs
[Musique]
on a commencé par regarder le veau et la
vache ensemble pendant 14 jours mais ça
causait beaucoup de problèmes parce que
liens très forts s'étaient créés entre
les deux et puis on les séparaient on
s'est donc demandé comment faire
autrement
c'est alors qu'il fait la connaissance
de cimetière vers cette chercheuse est
une spécialiste du comportement animal à
l'université on lui avait toujours
enseigné de séparer les veaux dollar mer
les garder ensemble et donc une surprise
pour elle aussi
au départ ce sont surtout des
producteurs bio qui ont adopté ce
système parce qu'il devait donner aux
veaux le lait entier de la mer pendant
90 jours il trouvait que c'était
beaucoup de travail de traire la vache
faire chauffer le lait est de nourrir le
veau ils se sont donc dit pourquoi ne
pas laisser le veau avec sa mère mais au
bout de 90 jours eux aussi font face à
des défis
il séparait subitement le veau de la
vache et ça causait beaucoup de
problèmes parce que leveaux était retiré
du troupeau il ne voyait plus sa mère sa
nourriture n'était plus là même ses
compagnons de jeu changeait
autant la mer que leveaux se mettaient à
meugler beaucoup et tous les avantages
cumulés jusque là comme le gain de poids
du veau était perdue à cause du stress
de la séparation
les éleveurs sont alors venus nous voir
et nous on demandé avez vous une
solution pour nous
commencent alors des recherches à la
ferme pour tenter de trouver des
réponses à la question cruciale du
sevrage chez corner la séparation se
fait par étapes au bout de trois mois
les petits veaux sont placés dans un
enclos spéciale pendant une semaine ils
peuvent encore tété leur mère mais
seulement à travers une barrière
roman wick août est gaëtan a pas une
semaine on rajoute une autre barrière et
les veaux ne peuvent plus boire mais ils
peuvent encore voir leur mère et sentir
son odeur
uk ns c'est une séparation graduelle
dans d'autres fermes cela se fait grâce
à un anneau en tissu ctions une
invention canadienne
c'est plus courant dans l'industrie
bovine de mettre cet anneau leveaux peut
rester avec la vache donc le contact est
maintenu et il n'y a pas trop de
différence puisqu'il reste au sein du
même groupe
avant le sevrage les petits bouts sont
logés à la pouponnière dans les tables
un endroit où le sol est recouvert d'une
épaisse couche de paille les maires
peuvent y entrer et en sortir mais les
veaux ne peuvent pas se promener
ailleurs dans les tables pour des
raisons de sécurité et d'hygiène
[Musique]
ça me rend heureux quand le soleil se
couche et que je vois les vous qui court
dans le champ
[Musique]
à la ferme de corner on s'aime cela fait
désormais plusieurs années que les veaux
sont élevées avec les vaches et il se
porte bien
le vétérinaire ne vient pas souvent ici
mais j'ignore à quel point c'est lié au
fait de ne pas séparer les voleurs mais
la chercheuse cynthia ferveur constate
elle que les problèmes de santé chez les
veaux nécessite moins de traitements
quand les petits sont gardés avec la
mère ne pas les séparer permet aussi de
respecter la hiérarchie au sein du
troupeau ce qui est aussi bénéfique 3
oui c'est
ce qu'on observe c'est que les veaux
résistent mieux au stress et s'adaptent
mieux aux changements parce qu'ils
apprennent des plus vieilles vaches
ils voient comment elles réagissent et
il les
imiter
mais pourquoi alors cette méthode
d'élevage n'est-elle pas plus répandues
c'est entre autres pour des raisons
économiques en moyenne une vache produit
30 litres de lait par jour leveaux en
boira de 8 à 10 autant de litres qui ne
pourront pas être vendues
l'une des principales raisons pour
lesquelles les fermiers n'aime pas les
garder ensemble c'est qu'ils boivent
vraiment beaucoup de lait
[Musique]
pour rentabiliser cette méthode
d'élevage chez corner en sem 100 % du
lait est transformé en fromage gouda
entre autres c'est sa soeur eric acquis
et fromagère la transformation à la
ferme et la vente directe permettent
d'obtenir un meilleur prix pour le
précieux les les nombreux visiteurs à la
ferme apprécie particulièrement le mode
d'élevage des génisses
les gens apprécient vraiment qu'on
sépare pas les veaux des vaches c'est
important de créer ce lien avec le
public malgache conakry
les néerlandais sont reconnus pour être
très sensibles au bien-être animal
pourtant la séparation vaches veaux
n'était pas une préoccupation jusqu'à
récemment
dans notre réglementation sur les
animaux de compagnie et ça s'applique
aussi aux cochons il est stipulé qu'ils
doivent rester avec la mer un certain
nombre de jours ou de semaines mais pour
les vaches étrangement cette règle
n'existe pas
en 2014 une grande émission
d'information à la télévision
néerlandaise créé la commotion en
traitant du sort réservé aux veaux dans
le secteur laitier
consommateurs de nuit un autre savait
que les veaux a été séparée et les
éleveurs savais pas comment réagir
montréalaise d'origine leslie moffatt a
fondé il y a quinze ans à hilsenheim ans
une organisation de protection des
animaux basée à amsterdam le
consommateur moyen ne savais pas qu'on a
enlevé le veau de la mer le sujet
devrait alors la manchette
les pays bas sont le premier pays au
monde à élire des représentants d'un
parti politique dont l'objectif est la
défense des droits des animaux en 2016
une motion proposée par le parti des
animaux qui compte alors deux députés
est adoptée en chambre le gouvernement
racines mois pour trouver une façon de
garder les veaux avec leur mère
finalement le projet n'aboutira pas mais
la conscience des consommateurs aura été
éveillé
avec cornet et d'autres producteurs
laitiers parmi la quarantaine aux pays
bas qui gardent les veaux avec leur mère
leslie moffatt travaille au
développement d'un label nous en a c'est
avec ces éleveurs là d'avoir un débat
sur le paquet pour que nous
consommateurs on peut choisir leurs
premiers et être sûr qu'ils sauront
compenser pour l'heure c'est un fort aux
pays bas une certification de bien-être
animal allant d'une à trois étoiles
permet déjà aux consommateurs de savoir
dans quelles conditions la viande les
oeufs ou le lait sont produits cartes et
les veaux avec la mer ce n'est pas dans
leurs critères encore mais ça va venir
nous on travaille sur les critères vaud
avec la mer sur les fermes laitières et
ça ça va être inclus dans leur système
des toiles trois étoiles nationale et si
on paie pas ailleurs sur le continent
plusieurs labels existent déjà
principalement en suisse et en allemagne
où plus d'une centaine de fermes garde
les veaux avec leur mère et dans de
nombreux pays d'europe la recherche sur
le sujet s'intensifie
chez korn et on s'aime comme dans de
nombreuses autres fermes on tente de
pousser le concept plus loin encore oui
des amériques
s'il n'y a pas un veau qui n'est il n'y
a pas de l'est mais quand un veau né on
a 50 % de chances que ce soit un
malik en scène on
attend donc il faut expliquer cette
réalité
tout est lié on ne peut pas consommer
que du lait et du fromage
la viande aussi fait partie de
l'équation et c'est important que les
gens en prennent conscience
la dares à terme il voudrait donc élevé
tous les petits veaux mâles chez lui au
lieu de les envoyer dans des fermes
d'engraissement
[Musique]
à travers l'europe les exigences des
consommateurs pour un traitement plus
respectueux des animaux bouscule les
façons de faire des producteurs laitiers
rencontrez-vous de la résistance oui au
début beaucoup parce que les éleveurs il
s'était un peu en choc d'abord tous les
consommateurs se poser la question on
enlève les veaux on savait pas alors il
était en chocs et les éleveurs tout d'un
coup il devait expliquer pourquoi il
faisait ça et bien sûr ils se sentent
est accusée défensif mais maintenant ça
fait sept ans qu'on discute et je pense
il ya beaucoup d'éleveurs qui lentement
sort de leur ferme en disant vous faites
ça j'aurais bien peut-être vous joignent
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire alors non
c'est maintenant une sujets à discuter
ensemble c'est pas une guerre ce serait
toujours une fois c'est au consommateur
de rendre cette fois plus populaires
je pense que ça peut fonctionner pour
des plus petites fermes de 60 70 ou 80
vaches mais pour des troupeaux de 150
vaches je ne crois pas car il faut
réaménager complètement les tables dans
ce genre de système
parfois on a un peu peur on se demande
si on fait bien les choses mais je crois
en cette méthode d'élevage et je crois
que les consommateurs vont nous suivre
[Musique]
need to be qu'ont fait les producteurs
laitiers doivent être convaincus que
c'est la bonne façon de produire du lait
et d'élever leur vaut qu on fait même
s'ils ne sont pas convaincus ou s'ils ne
le font pas pour les bonnes raisons
ça ne marchera pas voir le monde va pas
devenir végétalien demain les animaux
ils vont continuer très élevé manger
abattu alors il faut qu'on travaille
maintenant ensemble pour améliorer le
bien être animal
[Musique]